Tattoos have existed for millennia.
But testing what it does to your body?
That’s new.
And research has found the ink breaks down
and spreads nanoparticles throughout your
body.
But is that bad?
What does it mean?
Tattooing has a bit of a dark side.
The ink itself.
Which is not regulated by the FDA.
Which is fine.
You’re just putting it into your body forever.
When you get a tattoo, the ink is repeatedly
injected into your skin with a needle.
The needle penetrates the top layer and deposits
ink into next layer.
All this stabbing causes the immune system
to freak out (a lot).
Macrophages swarm to the area, and eat the
ink particles.
This is how they’d stop a bacterial invasion,
but unlike bacteria, the ink doesn’t break
down inside the cell.
Instead, the macrophage remains trapped in
the dermis, with a belly full of ink.
The big problem is, because it’s unregulated,
inks can use “contaminants and preservatives
like nickel, chromium, manganese or cobalt.”
There are 200 different colorants and additives
in inks… and no one is really testing what
they might do to your body.
In a new study, researchers attempted to find
out about one of these colorants: Titanium
Dioxide -- commonly used in white tattoo ink
-- also in foods, paints and sunscreens.
They found, the ink broke up into nanoparticles,
which might cause chronic problems with the
lymphatic system.
No one knows exactly what these nanoparticles
could be doing.
Or how long they remain there… we used to
just assume they were cleaned out!
The lymph system is the unsung janitorial
system of the body; it’s how macrophages
clear the body of waste and pathogens.
And, after a tattoo they’re tinted with
the color of the ink from your tat.
This was known, but people figured it was
cleared eventually.
Now, it appears that may not be the case.
Just make sure before you get your next tatt,
ask about their ink.
Because no one else is going to on your behalf.
Special thanks to our sponsor, Domain dot
com.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 20% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
If you have a lot of tattoos, did you know
you could be messing with MRIs, commercial
heart monitors… you’re messing with science!
Find out more here.
Do you have a cool science tattoo?
Want one?
Tell us about it.
I have an idea, but I’ll never tell.
Unless you ask me on twitter, then maybe.
Please subscribe, tell your friends about
us, and thanks for watching.